[Applause]
[Music]
hey it's almost June and you know what
that means
cicadas also e3 which is only a few
weeks away but there are plenty of big
games to get your hands on before the
Electronic triple kicks off don't forget
to hit that subscribe button to get new
releases delivered to you every Sunday
here's what's hot this week when it
comes to fighting games Tekken is one of
the top contenders Tekken 7 is finally
leaving the arcades for home consoles
and it's got some new tricks up its
sleeve the first is the new rage art
which lets you deal special critical
attacks when your health is low the
second is the power crush which will
actually let you continue attacking even
after being hit by certain moves from
your opponent add those to the game's
eight new characters including street
fighters Akuma and you've got yourself
quite a Throwdown you can jump into the
fray on ps4 Xbox one and PC on Friday
June second and if you want to see some
high level action before then you can
watch two pro players Duke it out in our
gameplay videos summer is also a
wonderful time to go for a drive so why
not do that with danger zone maybe don't
copy everything the game does though
since it's all about crashing cars in
the most spectacular way possible the
bigger the explosion and the more
bonuses you grab along the road the more
points you get what else do you expect
from a team that used to make burnout
games and you can compare all those
scores thanks to leaderboards 2 you can
take the highway to the dangerzone on
ps4 and PC on Tuesday May 30th Archer
would be proud danger zone if you're
more into piloting Starfleet ships than
driving cars you can finally do that in
virtual reality with Star Trek bridge
crew the crew of the USS Aegis is tasked
with finding a new homeworld for the
Vulcans and this mission will take you
to the trench a dangerous Klingon
occupied region of space 4 players can
put on headsets and get the job done
taking on the roles of captain tactical
officer engineer and helm officer you
can strap in with psvr
oculus rift or HTC vive on the 30th back
on earth you can experience a very
different kind of adventure with
perception this psychological horror
game puts you in the role of Cassy a
young blind girl as you can see this
doesn't mean the game is just a black
screen Cassy navigates by echolocation
tapping her cane lets her see objects in
her general vicinity but the more you
tap the more you'll alert the spirits
and the house to your presence you'll
have to rely on your keen sense of
hearing if you hope to get through it
all and you can give it a shot on ps4
Xbox one and PC on the 30th now let's
move to the other side of the world with
Tokyo 42 if the isometric style looks
familiar it's because this action game
is inspired by the original syndicate
and the top-down GTA games and just like
those there's going to be plenty of
shooting as you assassinate your way
through a citywide conspiracy you can go
it alone in the game's neon open-world
or compete against other assassins
online it all starts on Xbox one and PC
on Tuesday the 31st with a ps4 release
coming later this summer and those are
the biggest games we'll be playing this
week as always remember that release
dates are based on retailer listings and
are subject to change thanks for
watching guys and I'll be back with more
next week
you